[Musique]
waouh je suis impressionné
je suis ému par ce que je réalise que je
rêve d'apporter quelque chose de
significatif aux personnes d'ici de ce
pays où je suis né et où j'ai grandi et
je suis vraiment heureuse d'en avoir
l'occasion
je suis ravi de partager avec vous
quelques chose qui a transformé ma façon
de vivre je suis né dans une famille où
j'ai pas appris à exprimer mes émotions
mon neveu m'a dit un jour il avait 5 ans
je suis un homme j'ai jamais peur et je
ne pleure jamais cette phrase donne une
idée de notre conditionnement collectif
je ne sais pas pour vous commencé mais
moi j'ai pas rencontré beaucoup de
personnes qui ont été éduqués à exprimer
leurs émotions
la communication non violente est un art
de vivre
c'est aussi un puissant outil de
connaissance de soi et de résolution de
conflits
la communication non-violente m'a fait
vivre une vraie révolution
la première fois j'ai été prise de
panique j'ai vu qu'en fait je n'arrivais
pas à gérer mes émotions c'est elle qui
me diriger et puis petit à petit j'ai
pris l'habitude à connecter à mes
émotions et j'ai donc appris à me
connaître et à agir avec plus de clarté
et donc plus d'efficacité
j'agissais avant de manière spontanée
ensuite je regrettais je me jugeais je
culpabilise et en me disant j'aurais pas
dû dire ça j'aurais pas dû faire ça
vous connaissez ça vous arrive et puis
grâce à la communication non violente
en fait je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais un espace intérieur inaccessible
cet espace où se trouvent les émotions
où se trouve la vie cet espace où se
trouvent les valeurs les plus précieuses
et puis ensuite je me suis rendu compte
que le phénomène est collectif
nous sommes tous concernés ce d'autant
plus que nous sommes tellement orientée
vers l'extérieur vers la performance le
résultat souvent malheureusement au
détriment de la relation à soi et aux
autres je voudrais maintenant vous
proposer une petite expérience
j'aimerais vous proposer de trouver
quelque chose que vous adorez faire ou
vivre quelque chose de simple par
exemple moi j'adore homme quel fou quand
j'écoute oum keltoum je suis transporté
par ses paroles et sa musique pour vous
c'est sûrement autre chose et je
voudrais vous proposer de vous rappeler
la dernière fois où vous avez vécu cette
action que vous adorez faire et
peut-être essayer de sentir la vibration
intérieure
peut-être que vous allez sentir un
mouvement intérieur d'expansion de
détente
la communication non-violente nous
apprend que lorsque nous sommes en lien
avec ce type de bien-être intérieur
cela indique que nous avons un ou
plusieurs besoins qui sont satisfait à
l'instant le besoin qui est satisfait
pour moi lorsque j'écoute oum kalsoum
c'est le besoin de beauté de connexion à
moi parce que cela me ramène à un espace
intérieur de grâce est aussi le besoin
d'appartenance à la richesse de notre
culture et inversément
lorsque nous nous sentons fâché
contrarié cela indique que nous avons à
l'intérieur un ou plusieurs besoins qui
ne sont pas satisfaits à l'instant et le
mouvement intérieur va être un mouvement
de contraction de tension et en général
c'est désagréable
ce qui me fascine dans la communication
non violente c'est toute la vie qu'elle
l'emmène en plus à ma vie aujourd'hui je
suis devenu plus consciente plus
responsable - victimes - dans l'attentes
passif mes actes découle d'un espace de
clarté et je me sens beaucoup plus libre
donc plus efficace c'est pas un miracle
c'est une pratique
j'aimerais maintenant faire un détour
par les neurosciences pour vous
expliquer en quoi est ce que la
communication est si efficace en
situation de grand stress ou des
émotions intenses comme la panique ou la
colère nous avons une glande dans notre
cerveau qui s'appelle lamic dalle
cette amibe d'elle elle va être en état
de vigilance maximale en train de
répondre à la question est ce que je
suis en sécurité
est-ce que je compte
est ce que je suis en sécurité est-ce
que je compte en fait la nique dal a
pour objectif de protéger la vie
l'information du danger arrive au
cerveau et le cerveau ne fait pas la
différence entre le danger réel et le
danger imaginaire et nous allons avoir
des comportements réflexes de trois
types on va soit prendre la fuite soit
attaqué soit être paralysé le simple
fait de nommer nos bonnes non aux
émotions va contribuer à calmer ses
comportements réflexes et ce n'est pas
tout vous avez sûrement entendu parler
des deux cerveaux cerveau gauche cerveau
droit le cerveau gauche
il fonctionne de manière linéaire et
méthodique ils analysent ils calculent
et six se situent dans le passé ou dans
le futur
il pense en jeu le cerveau droit lui est
plutôt global kinesthésique c'est à dire
lié aux corps et aux émotions
il se positionne ici et maintenant
il pense oh non c'est le cerveau
relationnel
le simple fait d'essayer de nommer nos
émotions et nos besoins contribuer à
développer notre cerveau droit et donc
cela augmente notre capacité à rester en
lien en situation de difficulté pourquoi
est ce que tout ça est si important et
bien tout simplement parce que nous
avons autant besoin de chaleur humaine
de liens de proximité que nous avons
besoin de boire et de manger
il en va de notre santé psychique une
personne privée de relations ou qui
vident des relations toxiques de manière
répétée va être gravement atteinte dans
sa santé
marshall rosenberg a coutume de dire
chaque fois que l'être humain ouvre la
bouche il ne dit que deux choses s'il te
plait ou merci dire merci et reconnaître
les bons côtés de l'âge de la vie sont
un des moyens qui nous aide à développer
notre cerveau droit et je vais vous
illustrer cela avec un exemple personnel
mon père atteint d'une maladie devait
subir une très très grande opération
j'allais le quitter et j'ai d'abord eu
le réflexe de prendre la fuite
le coeur serré à l'idée de ce qui allait
se passer
ensuite je me suis arrêté et je me suis
écouté et j'ai réalisé à quel point ce
lien mais unique et précieux alors j'ai
fait le choix de retourner pour le lui
dire
je me suis je suis retourné dans sa
chambre je me suis assise à côté de lui
sur son lit je lui ai pris la main et je
lui ai dit papa
j'espère que l'opération se passera bien
je suis avec toi et sache que quoi qu'il
arrive pour moi tu es le meilleur papa
du monde
mon père s'est redressée il m'a regardée
intensément et m'a répondu j'espère ma
fille ce moment à laisser une trace à
l'intérieur de moi qui a la couleur de
la paix encore présentes aujourd'hui et
je crois bien pour toujours
j'espère que nous serons de plus en plus
nombreux à accorder de l'importance à la
personne que nous sommes aux êtres qui
nous sont chères à agir à partir du
coeur pour collaborer en paix sur notre
planète
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]